one time i came back from i remember
this i came back from las vegas
somebody give me while i was there a
rock of cocaine i'm not even joking
i've never tried cocaine as big as this
little thing's head
yeah it was a full rock i was like he's
like you want some coke i was like yeah
i do
and i was like all right i'm going to
the bathroom and he hands me literally
this thing was like
it was about two-thirds the size of a
baseball so i'm like it was a chill it
was a rock i could i've never i've only
seen how do you
gust so i didn't know i go in the
bathroom and i'm like trying to rub it
against my face
and uh that can't be oh dude that can't
be the way you do it
i couldn't even eat at the buffet the
next morning i [ __ ] couldn't get my
face open
but that day i had to fly home to l.a
right they're just rubbing a rock on
your face
yeah dude the whole way home and i even
dropped it on the bathroom floor on
accident
and it didn't break dude wow so it was
definitely i think it was cut with quick
crete
did you ever do it so i get to the
audition i am
so jacked out of my brain for doing
cocaine for a few days
i go in there and i tell the lady right
yeah this character would be a lot
better
if the character had this cocaine
problem
she's like oh really
it had nothing to do with the script are
you high on cocaine at that moment
uh i was still heavily under the
influence i remember having all like
these little sores on my tongue that
happened from like
oh my god just like the cocaine songs
will get on your tongue and then it kind
of burns it jeez
and i was like you know what would be
great it was like a it was like this new
age snow white that they were doing i
was like
is it the guy snow yeah
knew it was a disney
is that a cocaine coke head we got into
disney show out where they play all day
i've never tried cocaine this goes back
to like free will because the first time
i saw people do cocaine they were so
annoying to me that i just didn't do it
well you'll eat your neighbor's ass dude
but you won't want to talk to them
yeah they were like everyone's like but
they're everyone's like waiting to talk
next but by my car
but my car yeah and it's horribly up to
5am and you you'll [ __ ] get it
dude you will swap email addresses with
a dolphin when you're on cocaine dude
everybody likes comes up with big ideas
and then nobody can even wake up for
three days yeah
nightmare i am so glad i am not on
cocaine today
so i'm glad praise god hope you enjoyed
that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one